the truth is rarely pure there is a
rumor within the church it goes like
this long ago a party of Knights and
priests journeyed into the valley of
defilement the valley is home to
everything humanity wants to forget
outcasts the deformed the despised and
the aborted the party of knights sent
there never returned and the leader of
the party
the maiden Austria is said to have
become a demon demons take many forms
though all fall into three categories
there are minor demons there are major
demons and there are arch demons all
demons can be likened to the roots of a
tree spreading through an area and
gathering Souls just as a tree would
gather nutrients at the core of demon
kind is the old one an ancient being
that sends demons with one purpose
gather more Souls if we can take out the
arch demons we will prove ourselves as
the most powerful demon of all this will
open a path to the old one for the old
one needs powerful demons to gather his
Souls once close we can put the old one
back to his slumber instead of becoming
his demon the old one is spreading a
demon fog a fog filled with demons and a
fog that turns things in to demons the
fog has touched the valley of defilement
it is here where leapers the poisoned
the plagued and the deformed are
banished to live out their days in agony
not just the living are sent here but
the dead aborted babies can be found at
the base of the river all the foul nosov
the world runs into this place the
denizens of which struggle inside of the
impurity the poor dwellers are gaunt
infested and filthy yet they're adapted
with masks spouting long beaks packed
with aromatic herbs and spices that must
offer some small respite what exists
there would be enough to challenge the
faith of the most devout heart somehow
humanity struggles on within this place
food for the giant ticks the leeches the
mosquitoes the rats the most impure
being of all resides at the center of
the valley a woman turned demon who
apparently turned on her fellow Knights
and protected
upon hearing these rooms the church
sends some of its best knights into the
valley to discover the truth Vita the
moonlight Knight Rossio of Easter Elle
and salon Vinland many honorable Knights
have ventured into boletaria
in search of the valley of defilement
the vicious rumors about Austria offend
our most basic sense of respect for
God's name however none of these great
Knights has made it back could it be
that the wretched Valley is so infested
with grime that even our Lord's voice
does not resonate there or perhaps it is
the fate of those left behind by God we
find the corpse of Beto covered in slugs
and fall into the valley above the leech
manga is also the Zayas wooden spear she
presumably fell below to be consumed by
leeches people whisper that these
adventurers fell at the demoness
Striders hand ever since that demon
witch came here everything has turned
foul all the men worship her like she's
the Virgin Mary the same man who would
snatch my child away from me this was a
much better place before she came
Australia is indeed the Archdemon at the
center of the valley though while the
valley brims with grime it also feels
strangely pure but the last night we
sent into the swamp still lives and we
find her here now why you are one of the
sane ones are you not I am selling of
the West I seek my brother garl Vinland
the knight who accompanied Saint Astraea
on her travels
I believe they settled here if you
happen to see my younger brother please
tell me I must share with him the last
words of our Father I heard an
unflattering rumor about Saint Astraea
have you met that herb peddling woman
she claims that Saint Astraea is herself
a demon that woman has no reason to lie
surely she must be mistaken I find
something odd about this place it brims
with grime but at once feels strangely
pure Zelan holds the ring of devout Pro
which she intends to give to her brother
it is the sister ring to the ring of
sincere prayer a holy relic that
increases the power of miracles when
Austria was a young girl she found the
ring of sincere prayer a discovery that
instantly propelled her into sainthood
the ring they said was a revelation of
God a sign that God himself had chosen
the girl for great things when Austria
became a saint she took on the knight
garl Vinland Ghul was a night of the
Vinland family a powerful family within
the church and likely a friend of
Austria since their childhood he was to
serve as her bodyguard and whether or
not he was more than a friend
he served her loyally and the two
remained inseparable it's common for the
people of the church to embark on
pilgrimage a journey of spiritual
significance or awakening when a stray
learned of the suffering within the
valley of defilement she embarked on a
pilgrimage to search for it when she and
her Knights found the valley she must
have seen a land abandoned by God full
of suffering and those who were to be
forgotten this filthy woman tells us
that Austria made things worse but she
is simply jealous of Australia for
before Australia came the filthy woman
was the apple of every man's eye in
truth Austria did great good in the
valley her heart was broken by the
plight of the depraved and she cared for
them and healed them and they worshipped
her as a christ-like figure for she
cared for them when no one else would so
by the time the demon fog rolled over
the world and through the valley of
defilement Austria had changed the
valley had stripped her of any belief in
her God how could a benevolent God allow
these people to suffer the church wasn't
worshipping God it was more like they
were worshipping the devil so she made a
decision instead of fighting the demon
fog Austria embraced it becoming the
first human to successfully weather the
transformation into
demon she kept her sanity her
personality and her form the only one of
her party of knights to live was gal a
lifelong friend he decided to stay with
her until the end her demon power was
not used for great evil she tried to use
it for good
she resurrected the aborted children of
the valley she created a sanctuary for
the lost and the wretched and she tried
to cleanse the most vile place in the
world as an Archdemon she needed to
gather souls for the old one so whenever
a traveler or night came into the valley
to discover what was going on the
depraved travelers would murder him and
bring the travelers soul to Australia
truth is Australia is a beacon of hope
she is our only example that those with
a powerful demon soul are capable of
using evil for good works and given time
the perception of demons could change as
sage Freak the visionary says Austria
has proven that humans can evolve to a
higher state yet to us
she is an Archdemon and from our narrow
perspective she must die leave us Slayer
of demons
this is a sanctuary for the lost and
wretched there is nothing here for you
to pillage or plunder please leave
quietly you will not turn back with you
how dare you persist that intruding upon
our Haven you abandoned us long ago what
right do you have
we have humble lives leave us be
I shall let no harm come to dearest
Austria
may you rot in the deepest depths of
this swamp crude what more can you
possibly take from us stop
please stop this is our home we have
done no harm to you dear God have mercy
is not your abandonment of us punishment
enough how long must we weather this
cruel fate he covetous ones let it be
known we shall defend our half and home
to the death dearest destroyer
I have failed you
you you killed him didn't you
very well I can no longer resist you do
as you like take your precious demon
soul
just like Australia we committed an evil
in the name of good we kill an Archdemon
in order to rid humanity of the old one
and his demons yet Australia was the
demon using her power for good so ask
yourself slayer of demons to the ends
justify the means
you